o preta
favelada gorda deficiente física são
muitas minorias em uma jornalista
publicitária bori positivo
se para muitos a pessoa da primeira
lista é uma ea segunda é outra
lamento informar mas nós somos a mesma
pessoa e ser quem sou na primeira
categoria me impulsiona a ser tensão na
segunda
nasci no morro em nova iguaçu entrei
para a escola antes de completar dois
anos
aos três já sabia ler minha mãe era
professora no jardim de infância da
minha tia
ali consegui a primeira de muitas bolsas
de estudo
eu nem se doente e era nas salas de
espera que minha mãe criava as peças
mais lindas
ele me importava se tínhamos chegou às
quatro da manhã e só sairíamos depois
das duas da tarde era mais peças mais
roupas mas brinquedos e minha mãe
confeccionava eu tive uma mãe muito
sonhadora e esse sonho da minha mãe me
impulsionavam a ser mais a sonhar mais a
querer mais mas ao mesmo tempo e
infelizmente eu tive um pai abusivo
enquanto minha mãe me levava ao céu me
dizendo que eu poderia ser tudo meu pai
me tirava tudo e dizendo que eu não era
ninguém
eu cresci amadureci rápido aos cinco
anos teve de sair da escola para poder
cuidar do meu irmão de um mês enquanto a
minha mãe quebrou o resguardo para poder
limpar casas de família apesar de ser
professora
ela ganhava mais limpando do que
ensinando a minha história era pra ter
acabado ali
mas na verdade ela fez um hiato a gente
se mudou de nova iguaçu para belford
roxo la num bairro chamado heliópolis de
uma creche comunitária naquela creche
comunitária
conseguimos uma grande possibilidade de
nos alimentarmos todos os dias
infelizmente apesar da minha mãe tentar
muito nem sempre ela conseguia suprir
todas as necessidades alimentares de
três crianças e de marido abusivo
então entre os fios que ele usava para
nos bater ea e os nossos choros muitas
vezes
que ganhava na creche eu pude aprender
sobre artes mundo cultura me alimentei a
alimenta e minha alma além do meu corpo
ali naquelas paredes eu pude descobrir
meu objetivo de vida
meu propósito era ser médica e
jornalista para ajudar as pessoas das
favelas
eu não queria que nenhuma criança
passasse pelo que eu já tinha passado
eu acreditava que o meu trabalho um dia
ea mudar perspectivas podia mudar a
realidade
então eu estava pra isso naquela época
não existiam muitas ongs ou projetos
sociais na minha região
mas eu aprendi muito cedo que seu co
persistente e não ligar demorar cinco ou
seis horas por dia em deslocamento
eu podia fazer muita coisa de graça ou
com bolsa e aproveitar essas
oportunidades
seis ônibus por dia para muita gente
pode ser uma maldição
eu chamava de bênção porque eu lia
livros emprestados da biblioteca pública
do estado em alguns e descansavam em
outras mas eu tive um dia eu acabei
desenvolvendo um defeito e acabou
aproveitando tudo que era de graça então
aí é de graça
vou me inscrever gente onde morava não
tinha culpa de nada
esse pequeno defeitinho acabou me
fazendo ganhar uma bolsa integral na
primeira turma do prouni em 2004 e eu
fui estudar marketing
achamos que lá nessa faculdade era que
nem é hoje ligada à comunicação só que
nessa época não era ligada à
administração
e aí quando eu fui montar a grade do
primeiro período
são três matemáticas diferentes e eu não
sei se vocês sabem agente de comunicação
não gosta muito de matemática tá logo no
segundo período me transferi para o
curso mais provável que tinha lá que era
jornalismo era justamente uma coisa que
eu queria fazer também comecei a estudar
jornalismo e logo nos primeiros períodos
eu percebi que através da comunicação eu
poderia encontrar as ferramentas para a
mudança
social portanto achava que eu ia
conseguir só com a medicina
então eu comecei a me desenvolver minha
vida adulta poderia se resumir em dois
pontos de virada
o primeiro aconteceu em novembro de 2010
eu fui atropelada na rodovia presidente
dutra por um policial imprudente que
subiu a calçada não me ajudou em nada
apesar de nintendo nas audiências eu
perdi o caso e eu levei duas testemunhas
brasil é duro e aquele atropelamento
acabou comigo porque eu tava na
experiência no trabalho foi demitida
meu marido estava desempregado e o dpvat
não cobria a minha lesão ele só restará
senão que eu gostasse mas como é que
você gasta alguma coisa se você não tem
nada então eu fiquei meses deitada
chorando e gritando de dor sem dinheiro
até para comprar uma dipirona e muitas
vezes até sem ter o que comer
então quando o agente tirou o gesso do
meu joelho porque quebrou o joelho e
está quase tive suspeita de traumatismo
craniano
quando a gente tirou o gesso eu falo a
gente porque meu marido esteve comigo em
tudo quando eu tirei o gesso
eu no mesmo dia pedir numa postagem do
facebook pra se alguém podia me de algum
emprego qualquer emprego qualquer
trabalho uma coisa que eu pudesse ganhar
um dinheiro porque a senhoria queria
expulsar gente da casa onde a gente
morava porque a gente morava de aluguel
ea light tinha acabado de cortar a luz
então isso tudo eu parei de fazer
fisioterapia
hoje eu só tô andando porque o meu
marido e ajudou todo dia
apesar de ter recebido um diagnóstico de
que em três anos eu não ia mais andar a
fazer em oito anos eu continuo caminho
foi bem difícil era pra ter acabado ali
era pra que lutem me destruído mas
alguns meses depois eu comecei a fazer
estágio na secretaria de cultura
nós vamos pras favelas periferias e
dávamos oficinas de leitura e aquilo pra
mim era muito estranho porque eu tinha
desaprendido a ler e escrever porque o
batia cabeça e desmaiei quase tive
traumatismo craniano
não lembrava nem mais como escrever meu
nome e aí eu estava lá dando oficinas de
leitura era bem estranho mas isso me
ajudou pra caramba porque eu tinha
esquecido mas eu queria aprender então
estava rejeitada com isso e está
rejeitada eu pude aprender tudo de novo
e eu acho que eu aprendi melhor do que
antes
honestamente não sei se o suspeito mas
eu acho que eu aprendi melhor do que
antes e aí em prime-time e maria rosa
por 10 e poemas
eu pude desenvolver no meu texto e eu
consegui criar capas a possibilidade de
levar o leitor para dentro do meu texto
todo mundo que lê os meus textos no
facebook se quiserem podem inserir a
gente passa de cavaco
todo mundo que lê os meus textos me diz
que parece que está dentro dela que a
pessoa assistindo porque essa capacidade
foi desenvolvendo através de guimarães
então o jeito da escrita dele de voltar
e de criar uma poesia foi me ajudando
porque eu fui criando essa poesia isso
me ajudou muito quando cheguei pro jogo
a trabalhar no jornal o dia em 2013 para
escrever sobre ações positivas em
favelas e preferente no segundo ponto de
virada foi dois anos depois do primeiro
em dezembro de 2012
eu sempre tive um pesadelo estranho em
que eu estava dormindo e aí eu acordava
e não conseguia abrir os olhos
eu achava que estava cega eu achava que
esse era o meu pesadelo acordar cega mas
não era cegueira
eu tinha esse pesadelo estava cega e
tentava levantar caia no chão
eu não tinha forças para me levantar
então eu ficava meses e meses tentando
entender o que era isso
até que um dia em dezembro eu não
acordei eu fiquei acorda acorda tentando
falar pra mim e eu não tava mais
acordando e aí eu tenho que ir em uma
self e nessa self meu rosto estava
completamente deformado
eu estava desfigurada eu passei meses
assim desfigurada
nessa época estava estagiando e me deram
a opção de ficar em casa descansando
para poder melhorar logo só que nas
primeiras consultas e descobri que eu
não ia melhorar logo eu passei mais de
um ano de formado
tive que fazer quimioterapia por quatro
anos e meio
nisso como sabia que eu não ia melhorar
logo eu resolvi continuar trabalhando e
produzindo
eu fui diagnosticada meses depois por
lúpus dermatomiosite e fibromialgia tudo
de uma vez entendeu a tríplice aliança
do mal e infelizmente tudo de uma vez
enquanto a primeira doença atingir meu
rosto
a segunda atinge diretamente minhas
pernas e os braços ea terceira me
causava dores paralisantes e nisso eu
determinei que essas doenças não me
paralisar
eu determinei que eu ia continuar
fazendo as coisas porque eu não queria
que meus sonhos fossem adiados
então eu comecei a fazer um segundo
estágio começo entre um grupo de
iniciação científica
comecei meu mbi sem terminar ainda por
faculdade de publicidade mas já tinha de
jornalismo então podia fazer um mba e
comecei a fazer o mba e fazendo
acontecer um grupo de pesquisa e os
cursos por fora eu misturei tudo pra
ocupar a mente ao máximo eu dormia no
máximo 23 horas por dia
não sei por que mas os corticóides em
mim funcionavam tirar um som me deixavam
de formada mas tirar um som
então aproveitei essa falta de sono para
escrever pra poder fazer e produzir
coisas
em 2016 a minha vida estava no auge
eu tava no jornal o dia tinha a minha
coluna tinha acabado mas eu tinha um a
minha revista tinha acabado mas eu tinha
ganho uma coluna ea minha foto sai na
capa do jornal e tudo isso pra mim é um
orgulho e uma grande realização porque
pouco tempo antes um chefe me disse que
eu nunca teria a capacidade de ter uma
coluna então eu foquei como isso como um
objetivo de vida pra mostrar pra ela que
eu era capaz citada ela olhou uma vez
prometeu falou 'você não sabe escrever
isso não serve de nada e aí eu falei eu
vou provar para essa mulher eu vou
provar essa mulher
depois eu já atendi até a sua empresa
através da minha empresa isso pra mim
foi uma honra ea presidente dessa
organização vem falou você escreve muito
bem nossa tão impressionada e ela era
cima dessa mulher que o meu melhor mas
isso são alguns pontos da minha vida
em 2016 infelizmente eu fui demitida do
jornal o dia junto com mais cinco
colegas e nós não recebemos nada até
hoje então no meio desse furacão em que
eu tava perturbada com um tecido
demitida eu comecei a pensar o que seria
dos projetos sociais e das ações da
iniciativa de parceria nas páginas do
jornal
então eu comecei a fazer assessoria de
imprensa para poder ajudá los e acabei
formando a primeira agência de
comunicação do país que atende
exclusivamente acções de impacto social
agência isso em dois anos nós já
atendemos mais de 30 iniciativas além
dos clientes aqui de favelas e
periferias do rio de janeiro nós também
atendemos clientes de renome
internacional como britcom se brazil
foundation e através desse trabalho a
gente atende clientes do rio de janeiro
são paulo minas gerais nova york e
nigéria até atendemos a uma princesa
eu depois descobrir que o meu prazer não
tá em ser creditada pelas histórias que
eu conta
ele está
as histórias e pais saber essas
histórias são contadas
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]